i mentioned how our species our trees
cannot
keep up with the rate of climate change
the velocity of climate change
is orders of magnitude higher than what
trees can migrate at the pace that they
can migrate great at
and so we have to help them we have to
move them around
and this is only going to amplify in the
future and they need
our help you know we've gotten to the
point where we can't we can't just walk
away
we've got to do something to help them
migrate and be productive moving forward
and we can do that by retaining these
old tree neighborhoods
for enhancing regeneration protecting
the new seedlings coming up
housing the biodiversity and protecting
those carbon stocks
and this is going to be especially
crucial in harsher environments where
seedlings just like our babies when we
grow when they grow up in our little
human families they need our help right
um those little seedlings we're gonna
need the help of their mother trees
and so we and especially on harsher
sites where
there's there's more risks involved and
we can migrate these genotypes from from
warmer to to colder climates
as climate changes we need to do it it
can be successful
but it's going to be more successful if
we leave the old trees
around in fact we could be you know it
could be a disaster if we don't keep
those old trees around
it would be like you know creating a
like a parking lot to try to put your
kids out on it
you just don't want to do that you want
to have a nice healthy environment for
them
to be moved into and how you retain
those old trees the patterns
it's all got to be based on the land
watching the land
knowing the land seeing what's going on
seeing how it's changing
that means having people on the land and
knowing the land
it means getting out of our cities and
going out and actually being part of the
management of our forests
and finally doing experiments like what
i've done with the mother tree project
is wonderful for young people obviously
for students
they can go be part of it and feel like
their agents have changed
i can't emphasize how important that is
but also we can go look at these
experiments and we can say okay that
worked and that didn't work and that
worked before but it doesn't work now
so we can use them to calibrate
ourselves we can use them to
create models to project into the future
and validate those models
and lastly to motivate us to change
because
when we when we can see what what what's
positive and
helpful then we can we can emulate that
and build on it